[Music]
former president Barack Obama gave a
speech last week while campaigning for
Michigan Governor Gretchen Whitmer and
while he was speaking he was interrupted
by someone in the audience but it wasn't
a protester take a look I have to admit
that sometimes going out on the campaign
Trail
feels a little harder than his future
not just because I'm older and grayer
[Applause]
now while that was a fun moment I really
feel like it distracted from the message
President Obama was trying to deliver so
I decided to invite him on the show to
finish what he was saying everyone
please give a warm welcome to the 44th
President of the United States Barack
Obama thank you thank you thank you
thank you so much please thank you sit
down thank you and thank you uh amber
for having me on your show it's my
pleasure Mr President we are so excited
to have you I thought it was important
to give you this platform to talk to the
public without being interrupted well I
I appreciate that Amber I really want to
finish what I was trying to say or last
week
my fellow Americans there's a lot on the
line November 8th this is why I am out
here on the campaign Trail now like I
said before I am getting a little older
and a little grayer yeah but you still
find that I'm
oh no
oh no
no please ma'am please do not interrupt
the president well I can't help it he's
fine
thank you but but please I really need
to finish this message you can finish me
anytime
[Applause]
I moved to the craziest man the finest
person who has ever lived I second it
with your fine ass
you've gotta stop interrupting President
Obama he's trying to talk about the
importance of getting out to vote I'll
get out and vote vote that he's finer
than a mother
[Applause]
that's how fine this man is
even I can see it I can also see it I
can see it like this
I want to stop this oh my God I'm so
sorry Mr President no worries uh let's
just try to stay focused here
I'm sorry Mr President I am focused
focused on that ass
[Applause]
I'm sorry I don't even know where that
came from
we're getting distracted and we can't
let that happen because that's what
Republicans want no they want us not to
pay attention to what's going on in this
country and this election uh remember
that that the movie up you know the
dog's talking and all of a sudden he's
like squirrel you know and then that
squirrel climbs the tree well you can
climb my tree in in time
um baby I'm just a squirrel in your
world trying to get a nut
[Applause]
Mr President I I think you dropped
something you might want to bend down
and pick it up oh
[Applause]
so round screw Captain America that is
America's True ass it's
it sure is uh Brock knock who's there
Obama's fine ass
God bless him fine like wine yes we can
say he's got a fun ass
foreign
I want you to destroy me like you
destroyed unemployment baby
Rock in me like you ended don't ask
don't tell
daddy you've got to finish me like you
finished those summer bin Laden
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Amber yeah I'm sorry Mr President I
broke you're just too fine for us to pay
attention I'm sorry we're gonna have to
get the message out about voting some
other way so maybe you write it on your
butt
no
body
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]